combate
y el consenso entre el gobierno
colombiano y los manifestantes se antoja
cada vez más complejo este jueves en la
ciudad de cali epicentro de las
manifestaciones sociales durante la mesa
de diálogo los manifestantes reunidos
con las autoridades locales se
levantaron exaltados coreando arengas
luego de recibir información falsa de
hostigamiento a la primera línea lo que
culminó con la reunión denunciamos las
falsas promesas del diálogo mientras se
establecía la supuesta mesa de diálogo
para atender las demandas del pueblo la
policía criminalmente atacaba puntos de
concentración y bloqueo de la luna
calipso y puente de las mil luchas según
las autoridades de cali se trataría de
un malentendido el alcalde de la ciudad
jorge iván ospina se pronunció diciendo
que no hubo las condiciones para
continuar con las conversaciones debido
a las tensiones presentadas por su parte
el secretario de paz y cultura de la
ciudad reiteró a los jóvenes el llamado
a retomar las conversaciones
continuaremos insistiendo en poder
generar la mesa de diálogo para brindar
soluciones que generen bienestar en pro
de la comunidad brindando garantías y
seguridad seguiremos en esta labor hasta
que sea posible
con colombia' entrando en su tercera
semana de movilizaciones los jóvenes que
lideran las protestas piden al ejecutivo
de iván duque que acuda a las reuniones
y escucha sus demandas